now box2d was originally written in C++
ported to action script and used in
hundreds of games including the
incredibly popular Angry Birds and
recently the ActionScript version of
box2d has also been converted further to
JavaScript by Jonas Wagner for grits we
grabbed the JavaScript ported box G from
the inner tubes and placed it into our
source folder now if you have further
questions about the box to dapi that we
don't answer here we recommend you take
a look at the Box 2d manual shown here
and linked below it was written for the
flash version but the concepts translate
now the first thing we need to do to use
box to DJ s is to load it into the DOM
and we do that using this fairly simple
script tag